it is Friday once again which means I
have five of this week's best stories in
gaining all ready to go for you here's
the important stuff
bungie and warner brothers were in
pretty fierce competition this week over
who could piss gamers off the most
here's the lowdown on bungees are a
massive destiny backlash was headed
bungees way after they announced that a
number of exclusive items including a
moat would only be available in the
taken King collector's edition which
included the first three expansions and
the base game for eight bucks loyal
players were fairly missed that they
couldn't get access to this new content
without buying all the previous content
for a second time things only got worse
when Destiny's creative director told
Eurogamer quote if I fired up a video
right now and shows you the amount you
would throw money at the screen among
other chump sentiments after much going
on the Internet the saga is now rounding
up with the news that long-term players
will be receiving exclusive content in
the future on top of that now the
exclusive class items shaders and emotes
from the collector's edition will be
available as a separate twenty dollar
upgrade purchase on top of the
standalone forty dollar expansion and
yes that's still quite a lot of money
next up Microsoft has explained how
backwards compatibility is going to work
on the xbox one Xbox ship captain bill
Spencer told giant farm quote the
approach that we've taken is to actually
emulate the full xbox 360 hardware layer
so the operating system for the 360 is
actually running when you run the game
he adds from a performance standpoint it
allows emulation to work we're able to
get frame-by-frame performance
equivalents Spencer has said the 360
games act as if they're running on the
360 OS and the xbox one behaves as if
it's just playing a regular game which
will allow things like streaming game
DVR and screenshots Spencer has also
clarified that they would not be
interfering with code and that 360
Kinect games won't work on the Xbox one
this weekend free stuff here's what your
xbox live gold subscription can get you
for free in July Microsoft has announced
that subscribers will now get to xbox
one games free every month starting with
this election all month on Xbox one you
can play in a satin Creek game that
isn't crap that is Black Flag and from
July 16 to august 15 you can also pick
up so many neat for xbox one xbox 360
users can pick up plants vs zombies from
July one through July 15 and give a war
three from July 16 through to the end of
the month in news of Warner Brothers
stop ups this week Batman Arkham Knight
for the PC is pretty broken and it's
graphically in Syria to the console
version in short PC gamers are not
pleased peppered with glitches bugs and
a fairly significant incompatibility
with AMD graphics cards it's all been
going wrong in Gotham City this week the
pc version appears to be suffering all
manner of freezes framerate stutters and
performance issues refunds are being
offered by digital retailers including
Green Man gaming and steam and the
publisher has now suspended all future
pc sales until the issues are resolved
at the moment it appears to be all hands
on deck to desperately fix the numerous
issues including graphics card
manufacturer nvidia who have offered
their services and QA expertise to
Warner Brothers suffice it to say there
have certainly been furious gamers and
equally mortified Rocksteady game stuff
throughout this to barkal
finally fall out port is going to run at
1080p and 30 frames per second on both
ps4 and xbox one and pc gets to do
whatever it wants because it's pc
fallout poor creative director todd
howard confirmed the frame rate and
resolution to digital spy earlier this
week he explained that the game would be
quote 1080p on everything and the game
would run at 30 frames per second as
opposed to 60 but there's de later
clarified that quote the resolution and
FPS are not limited in any way on the
chichi let me know down in the comments
what you cared about this week and if
you reckon bundy your warner brothers
ducked up more and why this week on site
check out our review for her story and
our our opening graphics comparison for
batman arkham knight that is everything
that I wanted to tell you about this
week as always leave me your comments in
their designated comment box and I'll
catch you again on Monday